what i want to do in this video is make
clear the distinction between an
iterative
or i should say iterative i always
pronounce it wrong an iterative function
definition and a recursive and a
recursive function definition and a
recursive definition we'll do it really
by just kind of understanding where the
iterate the iteration is happening over
here and where the recursion is
happening here on the right so when we
start off we see that product is set to
be equal to one and then we enter our
for loop and the for loop really is is
really the the the meat of this
iterative function definition and
understanding what's happening in the
for loop let's let me make a little
table here so i'm going to make a table
for the value of our variable i and i'll
i'll also figure out what the value of
the value of product
product times i plus one because every
every iteration through this for loop
we're going to evaluate this business
right over here and then i'm going to
make a column for the new value of our
product
the new value
of our product so let me underline these
things
and then we have the new value of our
product so we learned in many videos ago
that in python we say 4i in range
this range part right over here this
range part right over here returns a
list
and it returns a list of the number of
elements that we pass number we we pass
into it right over here so if we assume
and i should have said this from the
get-go let's assume that we're calling
just to give make something specific
let's say that this is the result of a
call of factorial
factorial of
3. so the argument that we pass to
factorial is 3 so the the variable
number will refer to 3. so when you call
range of number it will literally return
a list 0
1 2. so 3 elements starting at 0 the
last element is 3 minus 1 it is 2.
and so each loop through this for loop i
is going to be assigned to each
successive element in this list so on
the first time through this for loop i
is going to be assigned to zero
so our i is going to refer to zero
and then
product times i plus one well in this
first loop product up here before we
even enter the loop product was defined
to be one
so product is going to be one and it's
one times
one
i don't want to do in that color i'll
just do it in the magenta i'll do it in
the
i'll do the entry one times one times i
which is zero
one times zero
plus one
plus
one and this and then our new value of
product is essentially this evaluated we
have it right here product is equal to
all of this business and so our new
value is one times zero plus one well
that's just one times one and that's
just going to be one and this that's all
we had inside the four little clause
because that's the only stuff that was
indented within this for loop and so
then we go back up so then we go back up
and we re we we're going to iterate
through the next iteration of our loop i
guess you could say and now i is going
to be assigned to 1.
so now i is going to be 1. this
expression over here we're going to take
our old product
so product is still 1 so product is 1
and it's going to be times times i
which is now 1 which is now 1 plus 1.
1 plus 1 and what's this going to be
equal to well if you evaluate all of
this you get 1 times 2 so now the new
value for product is 2 after our second
iteration through the loop our second
pass through the loop
now
it will go back to the beginning of the
for loop and i will be assigned to the
next element in the list it'll now be
assigned to 2. so i is now 2. this thing
over here we're going to take it's going
to be product well product is now 2 so
it's going to be 2
times
2 times i well i is now two
plus one
plus
one and so what does this see this is
two times three or six
or six
and then it'll go and say okay can we
assign i to any more elements in this no
we've run out of elements so now we
break out of the for loop and we just
return the product and we just return
the product or the variable product
what it's referring to and that's what i
should really say we should return the
value that product is referring to and
that value is 6. so when you call
factorial 3 it will return 6. so if you
were to say factorial if you say
factorial
of 3 plus factorial of 3
factorial of 3 and you were to evaluate
this expression
this expression would evaluate to 6 and
this expression over here would evaluate
2 6 because that's what the function
will return and then you would add those
up and they would evaluate they would
evaluate to 12. so this is why we call
it iterative we kept iterating through
the same the same set of instructions
now let's compare the recursive
definition and this is a little bit more
fun in a lot of ways so once again we're
going to call factorial of 3
factorial of 3. so 3 is our argument
that's the value that number will refer
to it'll take on and it says if number
is less than or equal to 1. well 3 is
not less than or equal to 1. so we're
not going to do this part over here
we're going to do the else clause so
we're going to return number so we're
going to we're going to want to return
number times factorial of all of this so
this is going to evaluate 2. this is
going to evaluate to number
which is three that's the argument we
passed times
times factorial
of number minus one well number minus
one is going to evaluate to two three
minus one is two so times factorial of
two
well that's just another function called
a factorial so we go back okay factorial
but now the argument is two so number is
two we go here if number is less than or
equal to one do this well the number
isn't less than or equal to one it's two
so now we do else so we what we now want
to return is the number times a
factorial of number minus one well in
this situation
in this situation the number is now 2
and we're going to want to multiply that
times the factorial
times the factorial of 2 minus 1. well 2
minus 1 is just 1
times the factorial of 1. well we've
just made another function call so the
the the interpreter has to kind of
remember that we've made this whole
series of functions calls and has to
keep digging deeper and deeper and
deeper so now we've called factorial of
one
factorial of one one is the argument
number is referring to one if number is
less than or equal to one number is less
than or equal to one now that's why we
call it a base case we're kind of going
down to it so if the number is less than
or equal to one return one
so in this situation when we call
factorial of one it literally returns 1.
and so we now know that factorial of 2
we now know that factorial of 2
evaluates to 2 times 1 so this evaluates
to 2.
and now we know that factorial of 3
evaluates to 3 times 2 which will
evaluate which will evaluate 2 which
evaluates to 6. so very different ways
of thinking about it but getting you the
exact same result once again if you take
factorial of 3 plus factorial 3 doesn't
matter which way we implement it we'll
get 6 plus 6 or 12.